541 euros 75 à payer en une seule fois
début avril une facture très lourde pour
cette famille aux revenus très modestes
là nous avons reçu la régularisation de
charges donc de chauffage électricité
sachant que nous recensons de 860 euros
pour une famille établie de trois
personnes
c'est assez compliqué je dirais c'est
pour les familles en situation de
précarité énergétique qui consacrent
plus de 10% de leur budget à payer leurs
factures de chauffage et d'électricité
que le chèque énergie a été mis en place
en 2018
l'énergie est un vrai enjeu elle et elle
est chère et donc c'est un choix du
gouvernement d'étendre ce dispositif
dead pour toucher un peu plus de
personnes qui en ont besoin
cette année un moment de franche comté
233 ménages vont recevoir un chèque
énergie
l'année dernière ils étaient 140 milles
voilà donc ces 65 % d'augmentation du
nombre de bénéficiaires de ce chèque le
manteau moyen du chèque énergie est
passée de 150 euros en 2018 à 200 euros
en 2019 attribuées sur la base du revenu
fiscal de référence et de la composition
des ménages
il est adressé directement au
bénéficiaire c'est un chat qui m'a aidé
j'ai eu un gros 140 euros mais ça m'a
aidé pendant je dirais quatre mois un
soutenir au moins deux factures c'est
vrai que ça m'a permis de souffler ce
vraiment utile un sinon on a du mal à
s'en sortir
et cela malgré des efforts importants
pour réduire la facture
le chauffage ce sont les radiateurs
électriques un des vieux modèle dont
qu'ils consomment beaucoup
j'allume rarement même en hiver j'ai
uniquement gerland c'est un petit peu
pour prendre ma douche parce qu'il fait
il fait bien froid chez moisson peut
descendre jusqu'à 14 degrés dans la
journée
en bourgogne les chèques énergie devrait
arriver entre le 1er et le 7 avril
ils sont utilisables jusqu'au 31 mars